sie kämpfen nicht nur für den sieg im
ring sie kämpfen für ein besseres leben
[Musik]
diese grube
noch ist er nur der kohlekumpel für den
ansager doch jared plan kann heute zum
helden werden zumindest für einen tag
[Musik]
24 stunden vorher seine lebensgeschichte
soll unter die haut gehen seit stunden
sitzt cheryls schon beim tätowierer er
hat sich für ein motiv entschieden dass
für ihn große symbolkraft hat
manchmal fühlt sich vater sein wie ein
kampf an
ich ziehe vier kinder alleine groß
manchmal ist es hart als mann für seine
rechte zu kämpfen und manchmal fühlt es
sich so an als sei ich schon mein ganzes
leben im kampf
deshalb haben die boxhandschuhe eine
besondere bedeutung
tätowierer tommy war eigentlich dagegen
so kurz vor dem turnier die handschuhe
zu stechen aber trotzdem glaubt er dass
jared gute chancen hat leute fragen ja
so stark dass er gerne kennen es heißt
er habe herz und geschick das ist alles
was er braucht
als erster darf der it-tochter erdel in
einen blick auf die neue tätowierung
werfen ihre begeisterung hält sich in
grenzen aber immerhin können sie sich
jetzt endlich auf den weg nach hause
machen
[Musik]
west virginia ist einsamer us
bundesstaat die arbeitslosigkeit ist
hoch
einst lebte man hier gut von der kohle
doch viele minen haben dichtgemacht
die bewohner west virginias werden im
rest amerikas wegen der hügeligen
landschaft oft als hillbillies
verspottet als hinterwäldler jared ist
froh ein dach über dem kopf zu haben er
hat noch immer einen festen job in einer
kohlemine
dafür ist er den präsidenten dankbar
nahm und trophäen ich bin ein tramp wenn
mein gefühl ist dass er die kohleminen
am laufen hält und sie wieder boomen
volles rohr seinen helm bedeutet ihm
viel genau wie seine boxhandschuhe mit
ihnen will ja richtig anerkennung
verschafft er trainiert in jeder freien
minute doch obwohl jarrett an den guten
job hat haben andere boxer ihn im
internet beleidigt weil er in einer art
wohnwagen lebt wie geht er damit um
das stört mich nicht ich mag in einem
trailer leben aber mein haus ist immer
sauber und meine kinder lieben
niemand kann mich provozieren oder
einschüchtern
was dabei herauskommt wenn man sich mit
ihm anlegt will george peter im ring
zeigen
ich habe noch nie zwillinge
gegeneinander kämpfen sehen ruft er an
sagt daniela gelten nippt an ihrem mac
gelten auch sie leben in bescheidenen
verhältnissen
der amerikanische traum scheint schwer
erreichbar
in diesem teil amerikas daniel und
nathaniel sind anfang 20 leben noch bei
ihren eltern den high school abschluss
schafften sie nur mit ach und krach
seitdem schlagen sie sich mit
gelegenheitsjobs durch derzeit als
tellerwäscher dieses leben wollen sie
hinter sich lassen und profi boxer
werden
davon träume ich und sage mir jeden tag
dass es passieren wird wenn ich weiter
daran arbeite ich tue das für mein
kleines mädchen ja ich sehe mich profi
werden schreien sie seinen traum profi
boxer zu werden
ich unterstütze ihn bei allem was er tut
was anderes wäre mir lieber aber wenn es
das ist
ich will sehen wer von und das alphatier
ist sagte stanley vor dem bruderduell
habt ihr eine abmachung euch nicht
gegenseitig die nase zu brechen
nein wir werden einfach in den ring
steigen uns unser ding machen
vater frank fehlte den jungs in ihrer
kindheit und jugend er 16 jahre lang im
gefängnis wegen raubüberfällen
ich möchte nicht dass sie in meine
fußstapfen treten in ihrem alter war ich
die hölle mit 26 kam ich ins gefängnis
da war ich den großteil ihres lebens
auch sohn daniel ist kürzlich mit dem
gesetz in konflikt geraten er muss bald
eine geldsumme zurückzahlen um einer
haftstrafe zu entgehen
500 dollar winken für einen sieg im
kampf gegen seinen bruder geld gestohlen
bei meinem alten job und bin dafür in
schwierigkeiten geraten aber ich arbeite
mich da raus ich lerne auf meinem fehler
ich muss mich um meine familie kümmern
kann nicht im gefängnis sitzen
das will ich durch das boxen schaffen
vorher zeigt ihm sein zwillingsbruder
schon mal wie ein standesgemäßer boxer
haarschnitt aussieht liebevoll sanft
geht er zu werke doch der schein trügt
ich werde es versuchen ihn mit meinem
haken ko zu schlagen in der zweiten
runde für das turnier hat er sich eine
neue hose gekauft in den nationalfarben
amerikas hier kannst du manchmal alles
schaffen was du willst nur unser
präsident nervt ja ich hätte lieber
obama behalte ich mag donald trump nicht
ich denke er wird den dritten weltkrieg
auslösen
und dieser ganze rassismus kran für mich
ist jeder mensch gleich wir sind alle
gleichberechtigt und er ist einfach nur
dann machen sich die beiden auf den weg
zum turnier
wie bei den profis geht es zuerst auf
die waage
dann weiter zum medizinischen check
alles ist hoch professionell organisiert
daniel kann es kaum noch erwarten in den
ring zu steigen
und auch jared macht sich bereit 2000
menschen wollen die blutigen box
anfänger vor ort miterleben
[Musik]
[Applaus]
die schecks mit den siegprämien werden
im akkord ausgestellt garrett ist bereit
sich das geld und den respekt der menge
zu holen
ich fühle mich ziemlich gut ich bin
leicht auf den füßen ich bin bereit
[Applaus]
ob der kohlekumpel hat viel wut in
seiner faust sagt der kommentator der
gegner ist chancenlos
[Applaus]
[Musik]
jared avanciert zum publikumsliebling
[Applaus]
ich finde es toll bekomme ich für das
bier und die kämpfe das ist alles was
wir hier mögen keine helme viel blut und
viel spaß
man kann ja sonst nichts tun auf sein
bars zu gehen ich liebe es macht spaß
[Musik]
beliebt beim publikum ist auch der
wettbewerb der sogenannten nummerngirl
mitmachen darf jeder
manche von ihnen träumt von einer
karriere als schönheitskönigin über den
erfolg entscheidet das publikum mit der
lautstärke des applauses
[Applaus]
frank der vater der zwillingsbrüder ist
inzwischen auch in der halle bist du
nervös ein bisschen warum ich habe angst
dass seiner verletzt wird
ich schlage ihn ko ich kann es kaum
erwarten wir sind kampf 24 ich freue
mich ich bin bereit
er wird mich nicht ko schlagen das
verspreche ich
[Musik]
haniel hat mit seinem zwilling daniel
keine gnade
[Musik]
der ko-schlag schon in der ersten runde
[Applaus]
[Musik]
und daniel hat es böse erwischt er
leidet unter starken sehstörungen
[Musik]
das passiert ich bin nur froh dass er
okay ist
mit den 500 dollar werde er feiern gehen
und sein bruder mitnehmen meint daniel
doch er hat den ernst der lage noch
nicht begriffen
[Musik]
daniel muss ins krankenhaus gebracht
werden später wird sich herausstellen
dass er verletzungen am gehirn erlitten
hat nach einem früheren turnier sogar
ein boxer gestorben
das show must go on
[Musik]
immer wieder fließt blut doch
veranstalter christopher michael smith
meint das risiko gehöre einfach dazu
außerdem seien immer fachärzte vor ort
wir sind bestmöglich vorbereitet es ist
ein gefährlicher sport menschen sterben
beim boxen aber auch bei anderen
kampfsport beim football beim joggen
oder vielen anderen sportarten boxen ist
nicht für jeden
für die jungs sein turnier eine große
chance zu kämpfen für ein besseres leben
in einer region die sonst keine
glänzenden aussichten bieten
es ist traurig aber wahr
ich fahre oft herum um poster
aufzuhängen und es ist sehr bedrückend
es herrschte eine große drogen epidemie
aber wenn ich vier fünf tage herumfahre
und verhalte ich mich viel mit den
menschen und ich fühle mich wirklich gut
denn sie sagen
chris wir können kaum erwarten in den
ring zu steigen du bringst so viel
freude in die gemeinde
[Musik]
[Applaus]
der zweite turniertag vater frank ist
einer der ersten am ring wie ist es aus
seiner sicht bisher gelaufen
ich hatte spaß bis mein sohn ausgeknockt
wurde
wie geht es ihnen jetzt
es geht ihm gut er ist jetzt zu hause im
bett in vier wochen muss er noch mal zur
untersuchung sie haben einen blutfleck
am gehirn gefunden und die medikamente
gegeben er war für zwölf stunden im
krankenhaus sein bruder nathaniel geht
in seinem zweiten kampf
[Applaus]
doch er hat keine chance bereits in der
ersten runde gibt er auf
[Applaus]
es ist schon okay das wird ein nächstes
mal geben
[Applaus]
auch jared hält sich nur noch kurz im
turnier
[Musik]
[Applaus]
doch er empfindet den ausflug in die box
welt nicht als niederlage sein leben
geht weiter
ich werde heute an den kohleminen
arbeiten und damit meine zukunft und die
meiner kinder verbessern
das ist jetzt mein ziel und seine
freunde mögen jarrett in kohlekumpel
genauso gerne wie jared den boxer in
west virginia hält man zusammen im sieg
wie in der niederlage
[Applaus]